my songs don't sound like each other
like country grammar don't sound like ei
[Music]
[Music]
i'm truly thankful that my fans allow me
to to do certain things like this you
know what i mean when it comes to music
as far as being able to be musically
free and
do music in different genres and and
still have um
success with it with florida georgia
line they are like families
we've been rocking together now for
about seven eight years bk and tyler
they
they're good they're good people man and
you know their family is good they care
and they love what they do so i love
what i do and i think
for the most part it just comes out into
music
[Music]
little bit is off of the new one
heartland where does heartland sit
in that you know that new exploration of
where nellie's sound is going next
heartland is is a nelly album but it's
country influenced
it's not a country album
i respect the art form that is country
music i respect the artists and what
they put into that
i don't live a country life to to feel
like i'm a country artist
but i haven't uh love and appreciate
country music and i'm showing how it
influences nelly
and i think that's what you want to do
as an artist to be able to bring people
together and to do things that
other artists can't do